I was really looking forward to
following professor pollutants because
so much of what we're dealing with now
is much larger than how do we design a
building or even how to save a little
bit of energy and one of the heroes of
the green movement in the United States
is a gentleman named Ray Anderson who we
just lost he founded a company called
interface carpet and he was a great kind
of Southern Baptist preacher and he said
he said Rick never forget every person
only has exactly one story to tell which
is their home so I'll go pretty quickly
and tell you about my story how I came
to this I my first green building was a
building called the Center for well
being out in East Hampton and was
founded by the gentleman who put
together the time warner merger stephen
ross and he thought that americans and
the first world would lose their
advantage because of our Eurocentric and
Western centric education and that he
set out to create global citizens who
would be fusing Eastern and Western
concepts of health fitness and education
that we're going to lose our advantage
you saw the rise of the east and the
fall of the West if we continue to
educate our children the same way so my
very first green building had this
background behind it and I'm a kid from
upstate New York on the Hudson Valley
that Professor plunge just spoke about
and it really brings up the issue about
what is this green stuff the sustainable
design and what the heck are the
Americans doing talking about it now
mostly Europeans had been way ahead so
we're best known for the building called
the bank of america tower one park the
one that you see here we were blessed
with the opportunity of designing it for
the same family who built and developed
this building about four times square
which was the first green skyscrapers
this really brings us back there are
those of us from upstate New York who
say the green movement started there and
the reason that I say that is that this
is way beyond saving energy or carbon
footprint it's about
the next generations and hood Michonne a
people the people who build long houses
that I grew up calling the Iroquois
Confederacy in 1142 gathered together
and they were the first participatory
democracy in the new world and 1142 if
you think about that those of us of
common heritage what we were living in
1142 and 1142 they elected the women
elected representatives to go to the
council fire and review issues of common
importance they elected one male figure
to go to the council fire in central New
York and at that Congress they agreed
that they would in there every
deliberation consider the impact on our
decisions on the next seven generations
and that's where this product line
called seven generations comes from but
I think the importance there is you may
see that you will probably see your next
generation you'll see your grandchildren
you may even see your
great-grandchildren a few rare people
might even see great great grandchildren
nobody sees the seven generations are
you planning for this legacy are you
thinking long term and for me that's
really the definition of sustainability
we started out designing this building
in 2003 2004 number one question we were
asked every place we went was how much
more does this green design cost and at
that time we were trying to get the
point out about climate change and
global warming which has become
commonplace even the Bush administration
accepted the IPCC climate change report
so that was a big turning point we call
it two thousand may two thousand six
when Vanity Fair comes out with their
green issue we decided that we had we
could stop talking about about these
issues but we love this this image that
came out in Vanity Fair of what happens
if the climate scientists are right
we're dealing with a really compelling
need to address this is it going to be
adaptation is it going to be suffering
is it mitigation are we going to deal
with mitigation Renee de bois in 1972
was was working for the UN and he coined
a term that I grew up with as it was
think lolly act locally and so we had
this opportunity in this context of
God that we had a chance to act locally
what you're looking at here is 42nd
Street this is sixth Avenue Bryant Park
New York Public Library Times Square
four times square the first green
skyscraper in New York and the site that
we have the opportunity to design a
building for us it's important what's
the sense of place whatever happened
here before this is sixth Avenue that's
Fifth Avenue and this is 42nd Street in
1855 what we're looking at here where
the new york public library is now is
the Croton reservoir dr pollutants just
spoke about the water infrastructure
that previous generations invested in so
that new york city has one of the best
drinking water supply systems we take it
for granted most of the world view is
potable drinking water is a precious
resource we've been able to squander
that in New York just because previous
generations have supported us so well
behind that what used to be called
reservoir park and is now Bryant Park we
built the exhibition for the industry of
all nations after Paxton's Crystal
Palace in London in 1851 Mark Twain said
of this building beautiful beyond
description you can see that the the
world of Manhattan was dense masonry
buildings the reservoir was this
Egyptian dense masonry building and this
is this first light airy glassy building
you'll hear from James Carpenter and
right right after me we'll talk more
about the beauty of glass this is a
close up of the building and that is the
very first metal frame all-glass
building in New York City they even
toyed with ideas of how to cut back on
the solar heat gain they baked
porcelains on the glass to cut down on
the heat gain and inside of that
building right here this little guy is
Alicia graves Otis as an otis elevator
and Alicia graves Otis they cut the
cable his safety break locks in and he's
and he says voila I didn't die in the
crash and this in 1855 he displays a
safety break many scholars consider this
the tipping point of the high-rise age
we knew how to make buildings tall we
didn't how to get built people up and
down in them safely so right across the
street is this crystal palace from this
from the site that we have the
to work on and we're thinking more about
crystals we we believe that people feel
good and like things that they think
could be found in nature or follow
natural patterns of nature this happen
to be a crystal from the Durst family
collection we were looking at this as
we're designing the building and that's
the building on the skyline now the
facets on the building were primarily
driven by looking around the building's
the cereal boxes around it were
primarily driven by that by the views
looking out but creates this kind of
crystalline form on the skyline but for
us one of the things that was more
compelling and I'll talk about that a
little bit later was how the building
connects to the street so this is the
corner of forty-second six I think
you're going there today the connection
to mass transit when I speak about this
building in some place like Florida I
say 2.2 million square feet not a single
parking spot not even one for mr. Durst
and in Florida there's a there's an
audible gasp like you know where was
everybody going to park we did a
calculation if this building had parking
according to typical American planning
criteria we would need a parking garage
eight stories tall covering entire
Bryant Park which is the front yard for
this building okay we're very interested
in how people do connect with nature and
this big glassy building it was
important to us how people actually
touch the building the first time they
touch the building is a wood door handle
and you'll see that when you're there
your overhead is a bamboo canopy on
gathering the space out over the
sidewalk and creating these oculus each
one of each one of them at twelve
o'clock if you stand there will frame
the Sun at the solstices and the
equinoxes and that's the building as it
exists now there's green roofs out on
this podium roof looking back to Times
Square we have Bryant Park as the as the
front yard and the building's tall
enough to be looking at into her
in connecting with Sun and sky so why do
I get asked to speak at events like this
it has to do with really rethinking how
we're going to build a skyscraper we did
not start by chasing after a lead rating
that was never in the decision it was
how do we fundamentally rethink how we
build buildings in America so we had the
incredible blessing of being able to
study every technology that was
available at the time we looked at when
we studied wind turbine technologies
none of them really paid for themselves
we obviously the Sun is both a way to
harvest energy the building next door
had photovoltaics there are no
photovoltaics on the bank of america
tower rain became extremely important as
a resource for freshwater bio crises bio
digesters methane capture a banking
institution has a tremendous amount of
food waste and paper waste that was one
of the one of the things that we had
studied and went very very far in fact
one of the problems we had is the chain
of command of banking records we could
not get a biodigester approved as one of
the approved methods of disposing of
financial records and then the earth as
as a heat sink we also knew although not
three we knew that because it was a
project of scale we could implement
something called cogeneration or on-site
power generation I'll explain why in New
York City that that was so important to
this project first of all most important
thing yes LEED Platinum if this was just
a code building on this site it would be
fundamentally greener than a LEED
Platinum building in the suburbs okay so
right now the greenest building by
performance standards is the NREL
headquarters it has a 1800 car parking
garage so the issue is how do people get
to work we are blessed with a remarkable
mass transit infrastructure system here
unlike a typical American city so we did
the calculations about if this was a
suburban office complex versus urban
because of how people get to work the
overall energy use would be 120th one
twentieth of a suburban campus because
of the carbon footprint and the energy
use of happy
we'll get to work if they drove so the
answer is an urban density that we have
no question about this and we're seeing
that the world is urbanizing very
rapidly each of us just live through the
change from a primarily rural planet to
a primarily urban planet and that's
continuing very rapidly New York City
subway car gets 540 passenger miles per
gallon I have a hybrid vehicle it is not
the answer mass transit just answer so
connecting to mass transit I'll go
quickly i know you're running a little
bit late but we have one point four
billion rider trips in our subway system
for an American city that's just
remarkable for European cities have
understood that the real answer for
urban density and high quality of life
is mass transit in most of the United
States we're having a really hard time
the project was large enough to connect
the bdnf with the Times Square stop and
make this underground connection for the
first time in fact we're waiting for the
MTA to fund the connection the rest of
the connection for x squared did nothing
with water so we talked about professor
pollutants talked about the water
infrastructure and how and how well
supplies but the other side of it is
really unbelievably stupid we combine
raw sewage and stormwater runoff into
water treatment plants and we pump
treated water out into our rivers okay
that's fine in some places in the city
as little as one tenth of an inch of
rain overflows our combined storm sewer
and we pump raw sewage directly into our
rivers just unbelievably bad and stupid
and we must change this so how do you
change it on a building collect all the
water you can we get about 48 inches of
rain in New York City we don't think of
it as a particularly wet climate we get
about 48 inches of rain in New York City
annually so we had two acres in the
middle of Manhattan and we set out to
collect every drop of water that was
technically feasible and the way we did
that was in a series of storage tanks
and we stored them at different heights
in the buildings one of the advantages
of skyscrapers is we have gravity
pressure to reduce pumping energy and
also down at the base of the building
the dirty secret about modern office
buildings is
cool then by sweating we use something
called cooling towers evaporative
cooling towers we make building sweat
and we use enormous quantities of water
cooling buildings so by collecting all
this water about 300,000 gallons of
storage downstairs we're using that
water to run the cooling towers it's
what's called cooling tower makeup as
well as flushing the toilets and other
uses so I never thought I would stand up
as a designer and talk about urinals but
but my partner said no Rick you have to
wrap your mind around this how much
water is used in urinals so we have we
had 54 floors we have thousands of
people working in the building and so I
was really embarrassed about the whole
thing and and so I sat down literally on
the back of a napkin I wrote out you
know the calculation on how much water
could be safe I had to check it because
it came up with three million gallons of
water by changing from conventional coke
implying your nose to waterless urinals
three million gallons of water here so
before my partner banned all these
little one liter water bottles from our
office we always had them around if you
took saansein how do you tell people
with three million gallons is so if you
take these it's 22 million of these 22
million of these so we're going okay how
we going to tell people with 22 million
is it's 2929 miles of these and then
enough to stretch from where we're
standing right here to San Diego
California of these bottles straight and
end every single year by changing one
technology in one building we must
change the way that we think about water
in our develop cities okay so back to my
more comfort zone we like to look at
artists we think artists see things
before scientists on the designer I
can't help it and so I think scientists
sometimes see things and they get the
idea across better than anybody else so
this is an artist named Richard box in
the UK he he installed 1301 fluorescent
tubes into the ground no wires all of
those are lit by the stray current off
of
right so again not being a scientist
what I say is I don't know what it means
but it can't be good I've seen dairy
cows I've seen children's playgrounds
close to these and it brings up another
issue is because of our distribution
network here in most the developed world
we lose a tremendous amount of power and
transmission loss in the u.s. they use
seven percent transmission losses as a
quick lingo on how much power is lost
when we're transmitting from central
generation to point of views and why
should we really care about that there's
another issue directly related that
which is peak or peeking we have a very
peaky energy profile in New York City
because office buildings have a very key
key energy profile we have a term for
our dirtiest power plants which are
called peaker power plants we've
actually done a pretty good job cleaning
up our energy infrastructure but we do
not turn any of our old dirty plants
away we have them sit there and the
terminology for them our peaker plants
you may be very familiar with this but
they tend to be multiples dirtier so not
what that statistic is ninety percent of
the smog in New York City is produced by
fifty percent of the power plants that's
how much better and how much worse our
power infrastructure is here so what can
one office building do about this this
is why we get beautiful sunsets over New
Jersey by the way this is a very peaky
profile as a diagram of a profile so a
typical office building has a base low
and has a cooling load think of it as
three o'clock on August fourteenth when
we had our black out a few years ago the
idea is to flatten that out and how we
pay for this is we have demand charges
here you pay based upon your demand
because con Edison has to supply the
infrastructure to hit that peak load and
they charge you a different rate than if
you have a lower peak load so the goal
for an office building financially is to
flatten this thing out as much as
possible one of the ways we do that is
on-site power generation and then
ice-making so this is a quickly a
diagram between a conventional building
in new york city right now plugged in
we're using about twenty-seven percent
efficient power we've lost about
two-thirds up the smokestack the seven
percent transmission losses you end up
with about twenty seven percent
efficient power in New York City it's
remarkable if you have hydro power and
with the nukes it changes everything but
with in New York City right now when
this thing's plugged in we're using
about twenty-seven percent efficient
energy so by doing on-site power
generation we have a 4.6 megawatt
gas-fired turbine producing energy on
site with heat capture on the other side
and we're getting about seventy-seven
percent efficiency so that's changing
our carbon footprint and energy profile
but most importantly the financial
attributes of it are fundamentally
different because it clips that we call
it clip shaving peak clipping and that
cogeneration facility that gas turbine
produces more energy at night than the
building uses so what we do is we have
44 of these 10-foot diameter tanks in
the basement filled with water we make
giant ice cubes at night 44 enormous ice
cubes at night and what that does is
we're using the cochin to power a
chiller a low-temperature chiller and
we're freezing the tanks and what that
does is allow us to melt that ice to
clip the peak at the right time it
really doesn't save any energy in fact
from a pure engineering point of view it
uses a little bit more energy because of
the conversion but it saves a tremendous
amount of money and potentially back to
our carbon footprint and pollutants
because of the time of use time of use
is a really important issue in New York
City I'll go over this pretty pretty
quick the other David to drive question
okay check check I'm an extrovert so ask
questions so we have giant ten-foot
stainless steel tanks inside of it is
plexiglass plastic tubing in giant mass
and they run it around we use a chiller
an absorption chiller to produce very
cold chilled water that chilled water
runs through this tank filled up to
about here with regular old tap water
that freezes each one of these they're
down in the basement there's 44 of them
it freezes that into a giant block of
ice so at night we're producing the
energy of the Kojak where we're doing
electric drive chillers making the
chilled water which freezes the domestic
water then during the day we have a
stored capacity of cold and we run the
system in reverse to cool down our
system as opposed to running chillers so
it's really just let it's a time issue
because the cost of energy at peak load
in the daytime is so much more than at
night good that makes sense ok I'll go
by this one pretty quick if the gypsum
manufacturing and cement manufacturing
globally are huge carbon the one that's
easy I'm an architect so it's hard to
remember a lot of things but one ton of
cement we produce one ton of co2 in the
atmosphere we've made great inroads in
New York doing cement substitutes the
our building uses forty five percent
last furnace slag all the concrete in
the building is forty-five percent blast
furnace slag reduces about twenty-five
thousand five hundred and sixty tons of
co2 from that one change that was really
pioneered down in Battery Park City the
bank of america did it and right now we
can get forty-five or fifty percent
blast furnace slag cement substitute on
any building in New York at no
additional cost yeah marketplace
transformation is a really important
concept that I'd love to talk about but
I'm sure I'm gonna round our time
okay thank you the other thing is that
it was really important for me to convey
is that yes although this is the first
leed platinum skyscraper we were never
chasing lead points it was about
changing the way we build buildings so
for one point under this rating system
by the US Green Building Council if we
recycle fifty percent of the
construction debris that's one point if
we recycle 75% that's two points so but
when you set out to try to do the right
thing you can go far beyond that so one
hand we we got two ninety-one percent
which is nice but more importantly than
that if we had crushed up all these
pallets and the big spools that wires
come on you know imagine how many miles
thousands of miles of wire go into a
modern skyscraper those fools are around
they normally get thrown in a container
of wood that gets recycled as wood and
it counts but it doesn't make any sense
because pallets can go back as pallets
pools can go back to schools but New
York City spaces the premium and it took
somebody like the Durst family to tell
the construction manager make space so
that we'll get a tractor-trailer truck
to come back pick up the pallets and
take it away in New York City speed is
everything speed of construction yeah
quality of construction is in our strong
suit in New York City but speed of
construction is so anything that holds
up the process is the enemy of the New
York City construction manager but
anyway it took the commitment of the
Durst family to get that done okay so
all of that said we we save about half
the amount of water that a building of
this type would use the MIT coat we save
about half the cost of energy that a
building like this would we were not
able to change the bank's energy profile
this is very important as we move into
the next week at that time in 2004 we
were just trying to change the building
that's why we generated power on site
that was more efficient because the
banks are banks we all use these things
we all use computers the energy profile
keeps on going up we all want more power
and more speed it takes more energy so
the way to pay for all this stuff was
actually in people energy is a very
small sliver this is a study done by
Rocky Mountain Institute
about a typical American service
business okay energy is that little tiny
sliver right there the blue are people
and their benefits so if we cut that in
half we've made almost no difference to
the bottom line but if we can change
health and productivity just a little
even insurance costs are way more than
energy so we cut the energy costs in
half it was about in in two thousand
four dollars it was about three or four
million dollars and this is before
everybody hated our banks and they were
paying bond traders three or four
million 28 year old bond trader was
getting a three million dollar bonus so
it really wasn't getting anybody's
attention when we talked about
attracting the best talent and retaining
the best talent people were really
paying attention so we started to focus
in on this how do you change human
health and productivity and the
calculation is that if we change
productivity just one percent just one
percent it's worth three times radically
changing the energy profile on a
financial basis so what's one percent
one percent is five minutes in a typical
work week so how could you how could you
get five minutes a day in a typical work
week so one was bring the best quality
air indoors that you possibly could at
any building that's ever been built for
the office market 95% particulate
filtration the top of the building there
are air filters the size of this room
that suck in the air at the top and
provide outdoor air heavily filtered 95%
particulate plus gas phase filtration
also supply that best quality hair you
possibly good way cleaner than if we
open the window the other one is how do
we get the air there most American
office buildings have overhead air
distribution that comes in very cold and
mixes the air also mixes dust pollen the
sneeze of the person next to you so and
the number one complaint in every office
building in America far and away is i'm
too hot i'm too cold it has to do with
human perception so you see the people
with sweaters here you see the person
the bermuda short shorts there you see
that we typically have these is a
Honeywell device that is then you know
was in our all of our lives you see the
lock box on top of it or it's that thing
is always in the corner office where the
boss has it
he gets to keep the temperature they
want so we did underfloor air with swirl
diffusers like in a car allow people to
adjust their environment and we did
underfloor air distribution so now we're
able to bring the air in at 10 degrees
warmer and we're able to deliver it to
be why does this help hot air rises
we're hot our computers are hot so we're
in a plume of air that's moving up we
use displacement error much less
pressure and the whole floor is a giant
duct and coming out of that swirl
diffuser it allows people to just in one
of the things that's kind of that's kind
of funny is that one we did not get this
approved by it's green or its comfort
what the bank came back to us is a major
decision because all the elevators and
stairs get set higher nobody had ever
done an entire skyscraper in America
with raised floor installation although
it had been done in European cities and
they came back to us and they said Bob
Rick you guys can tell people whatever
you want about why we approve the
underfloor air but I'll tell you why it
actually got improved approved if you
want to know sorry I guess year and he
said it's called churn rate the bank
churns offices at the rate of ten to
fifteen percent of their office space
annually in fact many offices change
before we built them and before they
even moved in they churned because of
restructuring in their in their
corporate environment and it's much less
expensive to move partitions around than
it is to move duct work overhead so they
calculated this is a much more cost
effective way for them to have occupancy
of this building in the long term the
other thing that's kind of interesting
is that in anecdotal evidence people
like it because they know they could
change this world a fuser I've have many
people like do you like that oh yeah
it's great I said have you ever changed
it like now I'm too lazy but I know I
could instead of waiting for somebody
else to change their environment they
know that they're in control of it and
it seems to cause a perception of
comfort and satisfaction that isn't
directly related to actually changing
their quantifiable results people are
hard to study also a big a big issue is
connection to daylight so we paid an
enormous energy penalty on the heat loss
side because we wanted connection to
nature so we have floor-to-ceiling glass
the heating element is below the raised
floor so we have floor-to-ceiling glass
we do that because it feels fantastic
and people react really well to daylight
so if you're going to do this you need
to do daylight dimming and you need to
do glass partitions on the interior so
you're bouncing light very deeply into
the interior you need to do daylight
dimming so you're harvesting that
daylight we waste an enormous amount of
energy by leaving lights on like this
when it's plenty when it's plenty light
enough with natural light okay and then
what we did on the outside is we used
the clearest glass that was commercially
available which is the lingo is low iron
in the u.s. we use the low E coating the
clearest loi coating that was
commercially available time and we did
something called a ceramic frit on the
glass tiny tiny little ceramic white
dots on the outside so this fog that you
see here on the outside your eye reads
right by it from the inside you can just
see it in this view but your eye reads
right around the dot to the Sun those
are opaque and reflect the Sun so I
asked asked Douglas Durst after he moved
in on the 49th floor so
second-generation green skyscraper
builder I asked him what his favorite
green feature of the building was and
you said the view so I think this is an
important point though people feel good
when they feel connected in nature so
i'll change scales completely we are
very encouraged that by being involved
in the green movement we get to meet
some really interesting people and this
is a photograph by a photographer named
kendra a zoo and he asked us to help him
with health care in the developing world
so the issue is that in 2004 China
urbanized at the rate of 15 million
people in one year so New York City at
eight million seven half million so to
New York City's moved from the
countryside to the city in one year the
earth has never seen anything like this
so this rapid urbanization and how could
we possibly deny the developing world
the same things access to good health
care that we that we've grown up with
how could we possibly say you guys have
to slow down
because we we don't want you to mess up
our quality of life I don't know how I'm
good conscious we can look our fellow
global citizens in the eyes and tell
them that they need to cap their carbon
because we've been enjoying it for our
lifetime so we got to go to Cambodia
which is a tiny little country happen to
deal with a horrific genocide and I went
there with this idea we're an adoptive
family our boys are c'mere by birth and
this is on the way to pick up our boys
at this orphanage in the background this
little Western orphanage in the
background and this is out of a tour bus
with other adoptive parents and I looked
at and I said that's what I'm talking
about the developing world can get it
right they already have it right it's
air-cooled rainwater collection shaded
porridge connection to nature that's a
little primitive Hut that's nirvana
right there so I said you know they know
things we we've we've forgotten but at
the other side of that same tour bus the
exact same moment out the other side
this is out the other side of that tour
bus choking congestion unrefined
petroleum sold out of little little one
liter bottles on the side of the road
horrific pollution and rapid
urbanization so how are we going to deal
with this this is our little building
under construction in Siem Reap it's in
addition to the siem reap Children's
Hospital the Unger hospital for children
which is considered the best a child
care hospital in Cambodia so we had the
chance to work on this is a real labor
of love and it was at that time the
tribute is the first green building in
Cambodia and it became clear that it
made no sense for people to send their
money to take care of the children's
health care while firing up
diesel-powered gensets to provide the
power because the energy infrastructure
is horrific and completely unreliable
you can't run a hospital off the energy
infrastructure so we had to generate our
own energy so that brought up is the
building now on the streets of Siem Reap
if you're there going to the Unger wat
temple complex you can go buy a day and
night it was intended to very
transparent buildings so during the
daytime the louvers
shade it so when you're inside watching
the people come and go from the hospital
you're kind of not on display and that
night when everybody goes to sleep in
the hospital the building glows and it's
kind of a showpiece for the things that
were done kenro Izzo said that when he
takes his pictures he captures a sense
of a place that he captures the love of
the place and he couldn't sell his
pictures because of the horror that he
had seen there so he sold his pictures
raised the money he raised he raised
thirty thousand dollars two of his
friends gave him 30 thousand dollars and
with that seed money he started a
hospital there and his point was that
every single one of us he's just a
photographer and artist but he started a
hospital every single person can make a
difference in the world you just have to
have your heart in the right place and
set out and do it so this project led to
something called Nagas biofuels this is
how architects kind of go off on wild
tangents I got really really interested
in a plant called jatropha curcas in in
Cambodia it's called the Han Kuang it's
a high nut oil plant that they burn some
places in in Africa as a candle as a
lantern oil it grows and depleted soils
we planted a foundation our refinery got
caught in customs the plant ate the guy
or was run the plantation took off with
our stuff it was just a story and how
projects could go horribly wrong but
what happened was there was a new waste
product in Cambodia and that was waste
vegetable oil that never existed there
is essentially in very poor countries
there's very very little waste because
everything has value so we had waste
vegetable oil and we changed the whole
project from jatropha curcas refinery to
a waste vegetable oil refinery and this
is our refinery after we got it out of
customs which was another whole long
story the tyranny of distance and
language and working in the developing
world and we're now producing about
fourteen thousand liters of clean
biodiesel producing all the power for
the Unger hospital for children the
Princeton hospital center of Hope which
is the best adult care and several other
not-for-profits and orphanages in in
Cambodia and the
crazy thing is it seems like one of the
best environmental changes that it could
it could happen is the byproduct is a
high-quality glycerin which is great for
cleaning parts and right now in the
streets of phenom pen and siem reap they
clean automobile parts & and motorbike
parts with raw gasoline which runs right
into the storm sewer which runs right
into their water system so we have a
very high quality glycerin parts
degreaser it's going to be on the market
very soon as soon as our labels are
printed and it looks like that might be
one of our best environmental footprints
completely accidental so as a wrap up
this is our roof here in New York City
oh you're coming okay great so this is a
sixth Avenue the Empire State Building
the sixth Avenue in 20 street and that's
our roof and the National Geographic
came and saw it they loved it they
included it in their special on green
roofs and the editor of National
Geographic said this about it which
makes a point that I'd like to talk
about just for a minute before I take
questions he said here's where being
responsible and attuned to the
environment pairs up with spiritual
satisfaction we cannot do the things
that we need to do if we're focused just
on energy and carbon footprint human
beings are very tricky we have an innate
desire to connect with nature the
terminology that we use for that is by
ophelia people feel good when they feel
connected to nature I think this brings
up the locavore movement urban
agriculture read knitting our ecosystems
that little that little green roof we
want we planted ourselves with sedum and
the first summer we dropped our roof
temperature from 150 degrees Fahrenheit
to 92 degrees Fahrenheit just by adding
atma sedum we're only this big then they
started then they started to fill out
and little bugs came and everybody
started sending emails around the office
like about the little bugs and little
flowers then we had bigger bugs
following them that we had birds
following them and
the end of the second growing season we
had predatory Birds hunting the smaller
birds we're reading a little piece of
the ecosystem I think the answer is an
urban density no question but when we do
that we can't isolate people from nature
it's where we feel good it's where we're
at our best so I think the other issues
of urban agriculture by Ophelia's the
terminology that we use are very very
important as we plan for a green and
sustainable future and we must not move
our food all around the planet just
because we can I think we need to start
looking at our food structure as being
much more localized as you probably got
the idea I could talk for a long time
about this topic but i wanted to say
thank you and leave you with one thought
EO wilson who is one of the greatest
heroes of the green movement and
globally he's a biologist from harvard
he's the world's expert on ants and he's
also one of the heroes of the green
movement and in the middle of our
recession which hit us architects
extremely hard we asked him like II you
know professor Wilson like what are we
going to do that all this Biophilia
stuff is great but what are we going to
do what's the future how we going to
actually solve the big problem and he
said that I believe we as the developed
world need a new definition of success
one not based on the quantity of things
that we have but on the quality of life
on Earth so thank you very much I
appreciate your time